it does seem that
you're really knowledgeable about
a lot of different topics so the natural
question a bunch of people ask this
which is
uh how do you keep learning new things
do you have
like practical advice if you were to
introspect
like taking notes allocate time
or you just mess around and just allow
your curiosity to drive i'll write these
people a self-help book and i'll charge
67
for it and i will i will write
i will write chapter one i will write on
the cover of the self-help book all of
this advice is completely meaningless
you're going to be a sucker and buy this
book anyway and the one lesson
that i hope they take away from the book
is that
i can't give you a meaningful answer to
that that's interesting
let me translate that is you haven't
really
thought about what it is you do
systematically because you could reduce
it and there's some people i mean i've
met
brilliant people that um this is really
clear with athletes
some are just you know the best in the
world that's something
and they they have zero interest in
writing a like a self-help book
but or how to master this game and then
there's some
athletes who become great coaches and
they love the analysis
perhaps the over analysis and you right
now at least at your age which isn't
interesting
you're in the middle of the battle
you're like the warriors that have zero
interest in writing books
uh so you're in the middle of the battle
so you have yeah
this is this is a fair point i do think
i have a certain aversion
to um this kind of deliberate
intentional way of living life
here eventually the hilarity of this
especially
since this is recorded
it will reveal beautifully the absurdity
when you finally do publish this book
and i guarantee you well the story of
comma ai
could be maybe it'll be a biography
written about you
they'll be they'll be better i guess and
you might be able to learn some cute
lessons if you're starting a company
like comma ai from that book
but if you're asking generic questions
like how do i be good at things
dude i don't know well learn i mean the
interesting do them a lot i do them a
lot but
the interesting thing here is learning
things
outside of your current trajectory which
is what it feels like from an outsider's
perspective i mean that
uh you know that i don't know if there's
advice on that but it is an interesting
curiosity
when you become really busy you're
running a company
part time yeah
but like there's a natural inclination
and
trend like just the the the momentum of
life
carries you into a particular direction
of wanting to focus and this kind of
dispersion that curiosity can lead to it
gets harder and harder
with time because you're you get really
good at certain things
and it sucks trying things that you're
not good at like trying to figure them
out
i mean you do this with your live
streams you're on the
fly figuring stuff out you don't mind
looking dumb
no he's just figured out figured out
pretty quickly
sometimes i try things and i don't
figure them out my chest rating is like
a 1400 just by putting like
a couple hundred hours in it's pathetic
i mean to be fair i know that i could do
it better
if i did it better like don't play you
know don't play five-minute games play
15-minute games at least like
i know these things but it just doesn't
it doesn't stick nicely in my knowledge
tree
you